for those of you like me
who have like teenagers uh story of
trust that will never clean up your room
when they tell you
uh and that's basically also a part of
this talk
nerd alert this was from a previous uh
conference but i guess here that's
there's no alert everybody
everybody's here uh and like to put the
scope down
uh we really only gonna focus on putting
things from
source to production so not running in
production because that's another field
of
dealing with tampering and so on uh
we're i'm not gonna tell you like scary
stories about security because you know
that's all too easy you all know that's
important i don't have to explain that
to you
i'm not talking about changing hardware
because that's another vector
you know nationwide attacks i'm not
going to go there as well
i'm not talking about like human
engineering or kind of
tricking you into doing stuff that you
don't want to do
i'm not talking about physical bypassing
access to your server rooms
you know trying to compress the talk as
much as i can
i'm not talking about key management
although it's like important and here at
fosdem
you probably want to manage the stuff as
well
um not talking about hardening your
servers
uh okay so we're almost there what i'm
gonna talk about tampering changing
things
unauthorized changes that's what i'm
going to talk about
um i leave this slide in here because
promise theory for those who know it
there's a lot of the word trust
stress trusting in there but trust
through verification
and that's going to be the crux of the
talk like how do we verify the stuff as
well
i don't have an answer for everything so
this is a research talk there's going to
be a lot
all over the place of things i found so
i hope in next iterations of the
talk i will get better at providing
solutions as well so but i went as far
as i could
from what i know right now in my
research um
so we're going to start with you know
the laptop it's i know it's a curse to
put like a
mac here and an open source conference
but that's a lot of the reality
uh and we gotta trust already the
hardware vendor we gotta trust apple we
got to trust the operating system so
i'm gonna take that as a starting point
the developer's laptop
with the certificate author is on there
you know with everything
and there and it's updated so i kind of
start from there
um these days
a lot of the development is actually
assembling more and more libraries
uh you know uh if you're doing some
development on mac
uh there's the app store there's docker
uh npm if your node homebrew
because you know apple doesn't provide
all the tools you actually need so
you know it's nice to have the community
but we depend on a lot of
other libraries actually to even start
our job
and get the information before we can
even start developing so the first thing
we trust is kind of all these kind of
external dependencies and most of them
are actually based on you know some form
of tls
verification chain of trust
and well you know i don't have to
explain to this crowd any configuration
ciphers uh you know all that stuff
certificates uh that we think that is
happening underneath because you know
we're using https
and it should magically be taken care of
right
obviously you know leaked or rogue ca
certificates but you know that's another
story we'll leave that to
the pros and all the ciphers and so on
um if you
[Music]
i'm taking this example of a node app
trying to push that to production
like the node by default has a lot of
cyphers it supports so it has to support
it because it's
quite open so we're trusting it but we
can get better at
you know putting this down it's it's as
easy even as putting some environment
variables
and kind of saying these ones we don't
want
so it's a simple thing you can do if you
don't
want just rely on node just doing stuff
and there as well um
i have to take my glasses on and off i'm
sorry
what's interesting is that a lot of the
we think about
certificates being validated yes most of
the time it actually validates whether
the certificate has been expired
but it doesn't look at revocations
so um for example you know you can
uh what is it crl and so on you can
verify it
but in several of the libraries
it is just not available
let's encrypt as uh kind of made this
better
uh but we're still not there yet um
if you want to go a step further you
know you look at the
ssl the certificate is valid uh you look
at the revocation stuff
uh the next step is actually like what
other certificates got created for my
domain
uh facebook provides like a nice
interface
uh to kind of check whatever certificate
that was created
in your domain so that's a way of
detecting work certificates being
created
under your domain that you validate so
you can put a web hook on there
modif monitor your domain and kind of
get information about things
certificates being created there as well
and if you want to go step one step
further you can put
in dns the caa record that actually says
well if this record if this certificate
has been created
by which authority has it been created
because maybe there's some dodgy
kind of ca that creates a certificate
for your domain
but here you can specified in dns which
ones do you trust
i'm not saying this is widely used but
it's like one of the trust verification
system
uh we can use uh in the system so we we
kind of you know
went a little bit deeper on https and
validation than usual yes you know it's
https and we're
happy kind of a couple of things we
could do
but obviously there's the next problem
is kind of is dns right
because we want to do a request
but we want to do a dns request and
um well i'm i'm sorry to say
it still isn't solved and many would
think like dns sec is kind of the answer
but if you look at what a few of the
major ones
like npm and github don't have the inner
sec
enabled so that was a surprise to me
i was like thinking yeah this is in a
sec you know everybody should be doing
it
i know it's hard but i would have
expected these companies
uh to be doing it um
even curl doesn't check it like
there's like a six year old open pull
request to do it like
my trusting curl has gone way down i'm
not saying it's not a good tool but
uh obviously it's people but the more
you look at the things under the hood
the the scarier things kind of getting
uh
there as well and then oh no okay we got
hd gps out of the way we kind of trust
that we got the dns
we kind of assumed that trust as well
and then the next thing you
do is like a homebrew says us like you
know run this
kind of ruby execute from github on your
laptop
how many have done that yeah scary right
um so i don't know why we
you know it's it's it doesn't seem to
you know
be able to get better to do it uh
there's a tool i found like pipe this
that allows you to actually view
whatever has been piped to the bash
command
that you can review the commands being
executed gives you
some kind of visibility of the things
that are happening
but again like we we just take that for
granted right so homebrew
right uh let's do it um
node is a little bit better in a way
that at least we can do the curl
uh download and check the validity of
the binaries
they have gpg enabled so which is nice
uh but okay i'm just going to go back
on this slide nope okay but it it still
is kind of a whole ceremony to go
through right
um i rarely do it but it's like one of
those things
it should almost get baked into the tool
somehow in the future
uh as a step that just says i download
it
it's validated it does all the checks
currently across
all the package repositories there's no
standard way
everybody does it differently and you
kind of have to figure out and sometimes
it's not even
well documented and you have to spend a
lot of time to actually verify the stuff
doctor was an interesting one i wanted
to have docker desktop on my laptop
i could not find it check some somewhere
on a website that
was able to verify the dmg that i was
downloading
the only way i could verify it was if i
install it on my mac
using app store and then i could verify
the signature
and that was documented but then again
we go through the chain of thrust
that we have to trust like apple and and
kind of go around that so
that was a little bit surprising for me
to see you know we can kind of do that
with a docker binary and
verify that as well
um okay i i got like node i got like
docker a homebrew
so now you know i'm gonna install some
libraries right
um
if you look at libraries how do you
think that the library is secure right
oh if
there's like a million people using it
it's secure
[Music]
if it's like been there a long time it's
secure
so i haven't really found a good way
uh obviously it's kind of like verifying
multiple vectors
but there is no kind of good way to
verify it there's a lot of vulnerability
scanners that will report these
cves or something on something but if
it's like a library not well know or a
new
thing it's like really hard to verify
unless you kind of download
or compile everything from scratch
yourself and go from there
[Music]
npm install is interesting because it
actually you know like many of the
package managers
just runs also scripts when you do that
so you can change a lot of stuff on your
laptop
as well so you can for example use
npm install with ignore scripts and say
well don't run it and get like a preview
of the scripts it's going to execute and
then do
the execution so it's like a next layer
you can verify
uh what is actually going on uh
underneath
uh it's it's very clunky um of course we
don't wanna have like uh
you know advertising in npm uh who
remembers this happening
nobody so for a while when you did npm
install
instead of only giving you the packages
that installed
it will just show advertising in your
cli tool
there was a lot of debates of something
happening but it kind of
you know shows you what these package
managers could do to your system if you
know this somebody
who wants to do some uh stuff with it
um so you you kind of do the scanning
you find all the bugs
uh one of the problems obviously is kind
of
all the dependencies and the libraries
like a bug could be
uh ddosing it but you're using it
internally
so even with all the scanner tools it's
really hard to figure out like
what what do where do i spend my time
patching so
that's you know one of the the problems
prioritization
to do that you can take a step further
of the
scanning of libraries and do it at a
proxy level like jfrog's x-ray
allows you to do the scanning and not
allow you when you download the packages
through an upstream repo and that
they're like secure or verified or not
so you don't have to do it on your
laptop
obviously you have to trust jfrog x-ray
but it's kind of
another layer of control you can put
there as well
so this was just to point out that
homebrew
the only thing it actually does is like
looking at
the checksum of the tarball or something
it downloads
so the actual recipe or was it the brew
that itself is not signed and the
maintainer said we're not doing that
we're an open source project we don't
have time for that that was basically
kind of the answer
so it's you know it's kind of
interesting uh on something we've used
we're using so much on our laptops to
install stuff that this is kind of the
state where we are
um you know node is a little bit better
they kind of signed their um their
dependencies as well
they have like check sounds but you can
see like this is
all manual steps that you need to go
through but at least you can verify that
you can get their gpg keys you can
verify the stuff
so that's nice and obviously when you
commit things yourself you can sign the
signatures
with your gpg key and push things to kit
but there's a i found an interesting
project that allows you actually
like multi comments or what is it multi
submitters that you're doing it that
there is like an
uh solution for multi-signing it uh
a commit so not only one person and then
you can say well
before it goes into production multiple
people have to sign that commit before
it actually
goes out so that's another way of
verifying
things there as well
you know if you're using github or
something similar you
when you push things these fingerprints
of the official host keys are actually
documented
so you can verify those as well instead
of just saying yes
i trust first trust and push it to the
server as well it can
kind of be like any anything that has
like a ssh key at that point
you can kind of push to but at least
here you can verify the official ones
that brings me kind of to a principle of
tough i
who has heard of tough few people so
it's kind of
known in um more in the docker sphere
it's spreading towards uh more of the
applications and the package
distributions uh so it's it's tough
stands for the update framework so they
kind of
made some principles and some guidelines
of people pushing things to repos
um so the separation of
duty is more like you know one multiple
keys and not one key to
kind of push things thresholds much like
the git
commit signing they do the similar thing
like multiple people
depending on the step have to kind of
say yes not only
one so that builds like the consensus
much
like um
was it the certificate thing i talked
about
uh the revocation of keys is really
important so it's built into the
framework that they can
fast rotate keys to make sure that
there's like no delay
uh offline keys so the root keys don't
need to be active all the time so they
can be on offline storage
and then the trust goes up for more like
shorter keys
to be there and no need for the key
sharing so
everybody can kind of delegate a key to
somebody else depending on what
the job they do so there's a principle
look it up the the tough
the update framework uh you know i'm
just rushing over here but it's an
interesting read as a concept
and this is what actually is used by
docker notary
when you want to have push images
in you know that are signed and secure
those principles are used by docker
notary so you create a key
you sign it very much like any of the
package
repositories as well and then you can
expect
whether it's signed with or correct to
like you would do with a git commit but
now with the docker image as well
this actually has saved a major breach
on the docker hub
by requiring multiple people to do a
certain steps
one of the keys got compromised but they
recovered in a way
because they had this uh principle uh
available
in in the setup we've talked about
you know note code or any of you know
ruby or whatever code
we talked about docker images but there
is also something you can do
for um verification uh for
uh for example for javascript libraries
in the browser
so you can build the checksum and you
can make sure that there is an integrity
check
when the code gets executed in the
browser as well
so it's it's you know the the check
summing and so on we just keep going
and we can verify more and more so
that's a good thing
i'm taking it even further we talked
about code uh
but you know this is probably the
simplest
uh way in the days when i was running
apache like minus t was my friend
to validate the code or the config
as well i'm not saying this is the trust
but at least
it gives you some kind of id of what is
happening
happening and if you want to take that
further now with
something like tfsec you can basically
check your
terraform code to validate if there's
something happening
that shouldn't be happening as well
i think that's getting powerful more in
cloud configs
that we can actually do that
verification as well
taking it one step further so i'm just
going up and up
so what if i don't trust my laptop every
time i do some stuff
uh i think uh jess rosali has
coined this idea of running every
application inside of a docker container
on the desktop
2015 this was a blog post
now there's been a couple you know
visual studio code
you develop code inside your containers
and then
we get better at exporting like
debugging it from remote
uh you know uh fedora has a
similar project um and
something like cube os goes a step
further they even give like
every application the way i understand
it they give every application
their own network their own everything
uh and
everything stays like separate and
ephemeral and it's actually used
in for journalists to make sure that
when they're putting things in the news
that they have like a safe environment
uh wide where they can edit stuff uh and
they can kind of
make sure that it hasn't been tampered
with
so one of the point is that i know a lot
of people say you know server scales not
pads but i think we're going the
direction that it's going to be the same
for the desktops
i have when i said that i heard like
developers screaming
like i i'm i cannot have my own autonomy
and so on
i was like yeah i've heard that before
like 10 years ago on the server world
giving pets names we were just
discussing that like pokemon names or
whatever
um
so we got the code verified we're
pushing it now hopefully to the ci
uh or uh we we pushed it to the git repo
and now hopefully the ci kicks in but
what's interesting
is that this often is outside our
control
so it's like who watches the watchers
who trusts
the people we trust so it's it's uh this
is a nice paper to read if you want to
know more
uh i don't know if anybody knows that
project
uh but yeah it's just you know it's in a
fun way it shows like anything can
happen in your ci system
that you you don't know that's gonna
happen uh as well
um and that makes you think like if you
use like a sas solution
how do we get that same trust we can't
verify the binaries
we can't do everything we pay them or we
use them
and we just assume they're secure so
that's like a big leap
up uh and i i haven't got any
you know perfect solution for it but
there's uh obviously
they get better at exposing what they do
so they show you the images they're on
your builds zone
they share that officially but we don't
have any id
whether they're running this image so
it's
it's still like it's better
some have a solution to run things
on-prem so they would do the same
orchestration
but they run it on your machines so at
least you can kind of
get audit logs kind of see what commands
get executed
so it's not perfect uh some would have
like um uh
more of um they would officially
announce that there was an audit of the
code
so that's kind of how more and more
uh they are building trust um
some would allow you to limit the ip
addresses let's say if your build system
is remote
they have you push things to your
environment that at least you only
allow the ip addresses of the people who
are
pushing something to you um and this is
a nice
you know little trick uh for example if
you use any of the
uh aws cli tools you can change the user
agent and you can have like an
ein profile that says like only this
user agent is allowed
so you can turn that into an almost
random
key by obscurity that allows you to kind
of say well nobody else even if though
they have like the aws credentials
can actually use that if they don't know
uh
the uh the random key that you put here
i'm not saying this is secure but it's
like
one step more the people from
uh the bitcoin system they went a step
further so they just went
with what if we have multiple people
compile it
and then verify if this gives us the
same result
and then if most of the people get the
same result we assume
that is the best result and then we put
the checksum
in so not only one checksum because
your tooling might be infected and just
changing it there as well
so i found that a nice way we we
sometimes think about multi-cloud
what about multiple ci what about using
two ci systems
and then do like verification and see if
both kind of created the same thing
uh again it's like thinking i'm not
saying this is
actually being done but it gives you
some inspiration
but this brings us to the hard point of
doing reproducible builds
which isn't really that easy because
let's say you have like a something uh
like a time in your banner or your
header
or already uh whatever and you're kind
of recompiling it
the next time you compile it you know
the binary will be different
uh or the flags from the compiler or
anything there so
um debian has spent a lot of time on
making
packages and builds reproducible um
node if i run it twice on my same
laptop with the same compiler in the
same settings the binary
or whatever it builds will not give me
the same checksum
so it's something that i found
interesting to to
to see we would think like it checks on
this is kind of
what we do
one more step further what about
uh the operating system itself um
it turns out that this was from a fosdem
talk
to build a linux nowadays you have to
have a linux
right so somewhere we lost the link from
being completely from scratch
to build the linux system uh sometimes
you see like bootstrap one two three
when you do like gcc compiling like some
of the bootstrapping
is binary only so people are still
working on making that code
as well so it's it's sometimes hard to
verify
uh to do that if you want to have a look
at this this is
i think there was a talk earlier today
on that as well grix
sd like all the dependencies of the
libraries it's not that easy
as it looks uh and even
like the bootstrapping assembler uh
that you know people are working on that
just to have like a from source
verifiable compiler uh to make things
happen
i'm gonna skip that slide that's like
right
so we kind of said well make it
repeatable make it repeatable
and then the hacker say fantastic now i
can detect every binary because
if i look at the checksum i know what
binary it is
so then this company said well you know
what we're going to build a wrapper
that randomizes the checksums again to
run it in production and then we mop it
on the static uh
checksums again so it's kind of you know
we're going round and round but you know
we're getting better
the checksumming is one thing i talked
about
thinking about all the dependencies i
think this is where google bazel comes
in that
they instead of saying reproducible
builds which
built this in binary they're working on
uh the concept of
hermetic builds where all the
dependencies that you need in the build
for your docker image or whatever they
are specified
it is not just app get update or
something
they kind of try to do that as well and
not only for your dependencies but all
your
also for your compiling toolchain so
bazel will download
a known set of compilers so that
everybody in your team will use the same
compilers
and do the same installation as well
and that brings us you know the attack
factors quite often the discussion is on
containers like hello there's so much in
the container and
there's so much vulnerabilities and
they're actually going the direction
what if we only need like one binary
in the container so distro less and that
you know makes it a lot more difficult
to do any attack vector
there this
is what some people are working on so we
when we know all the dependencies we
kind of have like a bill of material
you know like the ingredient list this
code has been built with this
dependencies
and so on um
well there's many tools that allow you
to reverge engineer
docker files because it's sometimes not
that easy and you don't know what's
inside
you can take multiple approaches either
from forensics or reverse engineering
they're all in the notes you can see
that later this is some interesting
stuff
but you know it's stupid that we throw
away
all the meta information while building
and then
have to reverse it engineer it again uh
i
in my past company i worked on uh video
stuff
and it's almost like uh when you have a
dvd
i know that's getting old uh with
subtitles
you know and you have to reverse
engineer it from the image but it will
that's actually stupid
in todo is a new not new but it
goes one step further they actually not
only specify the dependency
sources but also the steps that they
took
while doing the build so they would
sign every step of the build so you can
verify what happened
during the build as well and then
graphias in the docker x system can use
all that metadata
to decide whether something should run
in production or not
uh based on what has been in the image
when a new vulnerability comes out they
can
kind of say well you know this is kind
of something that this
has been built now we know there's a
severity one
so you have to do about it but that's
something that can be integrated there
as well
but obviously you know it never ends and
we just keep going
there as well so
i'm getting toward the end of my talk i
know
all the tools that i've shown you are so
hard to use right
and sometimes i think about it um
we thought fought so hard to get the
right to vote
but then you would say well i don't want
to vote right
and it's a little bit like this we
fought so hard about getting the freedom
for
you know using sharing libraries and so
on and i think we kind of have to get
better at the verification step because
you know
that's one of the duties we have as well
to make our ecosystem more secure in
there
um and i think a lot of it has to do
with the transparency
transparency building consensus so not
like
one group saying yes or no but work on
there as well
so i think that was basically my thought
i don't have time for questions
okay anyone yeah okay
i know there's quite some debate whether
it's useful or not
uh yeah uh but um
i think um
if you automate it that's one of the
problems uh because if it's
if it's just like uh i will do the from
what i understand
the the argument is about when you
automate the step then
it's no use because it's uh
there is no real verification happening
i don't know if if you have another
id on on there for instance not to build
something that is not
signing properly um
yeah but sometimes you have to i guess
no is it possible are there any tools
that they can use to prevent build
something
oh okay i think the question was uh
is there a yeah okay i'm gonna repeat
the second one so
uh that uh that can prevent um
a build from happening if some the the
commit hasn't been signed
i think that is probably looking at the
verification
and then putting an exit code i don't
know i haven't come across
any specific tool in there so
yeah well very interesting by the way
thank you for the representation it was
really really good
you talk about the pipeline what
happened what is already in production
yeah okay so that's another talk like i
said yeah
um because i think that's more dangerous
actually though
it is more dangerous uh but um i think
it's it's another you know it's another
aspect of looking at things
i i i think here i want to go in the
prevention mode
and not in the you know even if you're
going to prevention mode
i mean the hacker sure
is quite fast i mean the community is
quite fast trying to find
vulnerabilities and things that are
disclosure already but the companies
didn't have time to budget
yes but but the visibility
of knowing what is running production
and i'm not talking about intrusion
detection or logging or auditing but
if you know what is happening and you
can at least know
check the vulnerability databases and
get some of the tools that do that
you get you are better informed whether
you should kind of
you know patch the zero day or kind of
as fast as possible
uh i'm not saying you don't have to
protect your servers anymore
but at least the visibility is it's what
i try to show here
if you verify and get things visible at
least you can
see it if you don't know it you just
yeah live in
happiness so that might be good as well
so
one more question one more yeah
checking like 1 hashes or something from
downloading
yeah that is what um i think
most of the distro the the package
managers are using
um yeah my question is if the
file is like downloaded over https
connection already
and then i use a checksum from the same
source
to check the downloaded file against
besides accidental transmission errors
would that
provide any additional security
it depends it could it could not right
um
if you're saying
if if i have like an s3 repository and
my binary is here and my checksum
is here you know on the same bucket and
i have access
you know yes i can alter both so that's
not really a solution
but if i have the checksums on a website
something else on a different system
and i have my barriers here yes it makes
sense
okay but from the same source no but it
depends what you define as same source
is it the same company is it
another company is it the same website
same server so it's kind of
depending on you know the more the
more people are seeing it the the better
it gets there
yes okay i'm sorry
find the ottawa